♪ ♪
>> HELLO, EVERYONE PARADIGM
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO ALONG WITH
JUST JESSICA TARLOV,
MARTHA MacCALLUM, AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
HE HAS PROMISED TO UNITE
AMERICA, BUT NOW JOE BIDEN IS.
HALF THE COUNTRY IS EXTREMIST
WITH HIS POLL NUMBERS IN THREE
FALL AND HIS HEADED FOR A
WHITE HOUSE WIPE OUT THE
MIDTERM.
>> LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THIS
AGENDA.
IT IS EXTREME ASTHMA FAR.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR REPUBLICANS
TALK ABOUT DEFICITS AND THEIR
ULTRA MAGA AGENDA.
THESE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
I DON'T WANT TO MISPRONOUNCE
THAT.
THIS MAGA CROWD IS REALLY THE
MOST EXTREME POLITICAL
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS EXISTED IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> MR. UNITY SEEMS TO FORGET
THAT IT IS HIS PARTY THAT IS
FULL OF EXTREMISTS.
FAR LEFT DEMOCRATS LIKE THE
SQUAD WANT TO DEFUND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS EVERYWHERE.
THEY WANT TO OPEN THE BORDER,
WIDE OPEN TO CRIMINAL CARTELS BY
LETTING TITLE 42 EXPIRE.
THEY WANT TO PUSH THEIR IDEOLOGY
INTO EVERY FACET OF LIFE.
BIDEN IGNITING A BACKLASH WITH
HIS COMMENTS.
>> ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT THIS
"MAGA" CROWD IS WORSE THAN
TERRORISTS.
NO MATTER HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
MAGA CROWD, THIS IS AN
AUTHORITARIAN ASSAULT ON OUR
FREEDOM.
>> I THOUGHT JOE BIDEN WANTED TO
STAND FOR UNITY.
HE >> MARTHA, YOU HAD A LOT ON
THIS.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THIS IS
JOE BIDEN'S DEPLORABLE MOMENT.
A GUY THAT IS SO LOW IN TERMS OF
THE MIDTERMS IN JUST UNDER SIX
MONTHS.
WHY ARE THEY CALLING EVERYONE
ELSE DEPLORABLE?
>> YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SUPPORTERS
AND TRUMP CANDIDATES THINK SO,
THEY GIVE, THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE MADE IT.
HE HAS A JUST AND ALIENATED HAVE
THE OTHER COUNTRY.
HE IS PULLED AGAINST HIS OWN
FORMER THINKING.
HE COULD BE TAKING THIS MOMENT
AND SAYING, I UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
FEEL.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT WITH THE
JUSTICES ARE GOING TO DECIDE,
BECAUSE I WANT FELT THAT WAY
MYSELF.
IN FACT, AS THE SENATOR HE SAID
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION ON ABORTION.
I THINK IT WENT TOO FAR.
THEN HE SAID WHEN HE WAS A
PROPONENT WITH REPUBLICANS UNDER
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION OF
DOING EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, SCRATCHING
ROE V. WADE AND SEND IT BACK TO
THE STATES, HE ADVOCATED FOR
THAT.
HE WANTED TO VOTE FOR THAT
AMENDMENT.
HE SAID IT WAS BECAUSE I WAS A
ROMAN CATHOLIC.
A VICTIM, OR WHATEVER.
HE'S ALIENATED EVERYONE.
THE TRUTH IS THAT SOME PEOPLE
ARE SOMEWHAT MORE IN THE MIDDLE
ON THIS ISSUE.
OUR OWN FOX NEWS POLL, 54% OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ANSWERED AT THINK
THAT 15 WEEKS IS WHERE THE BAND
SHOULD BE.
15 WEEKS IS WHAT THE MISSISSIPPI
LAW WAS ABOUT.
IT LINES UP WITH WHAT YOU SEE IN
MOST OF EUROPE.
THIS IS NOT A RADICAL OPINION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW PEOPLE
STAND ON THIS.
I THINK THIS IS AN ONLINE
DECISION FOR HIM POLITICALLY AND
I THINK THAT HE'S GOING TO SORT
OF FEED RIGHT INTO THE HANDS OF
WHAT HIS OPPOSITIONS GOING TO
BE.
>> JUST GOT, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT BIDEN SAID THAT REALLY
STUNNED ME WAS THAT HE SET UP
I'M NOT PREPARED TO LEAVE IF SHE
WAS OF PRIVACY TO THE WHIMS OF
THE PUBLIC."
IF HE SO CONVINCED THAT THE
COURT IS SO WRONG, WHY ARE THEY
WILLING TO LET THE STATES
DECIDE?
LET CONGRESS PASSED THE LAW.
>> CONGRESS WILL PASS THE LAW,
OR THEY WILL TRY TO NEXT WEEK.
I SAW SOMETHING I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY SMART.
THERE ARE 13 STATES RIGHT NOW
THAT IF THE DRAFT COMES TO
FRUITION WILL IMMEDIATELY MAKE
ABORTION ILLEGAL OR IT WILL GO
TO SIX WEEKS AND THAT IS MAKING
IT ILLEGAL.
HAVE SOME THINGS A LITTLE MORE
MODERATE TO GET IT DONE.
AND BY SOME PRAYER OF PASSING
THE SENATE.
IN THE HOUSE, HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT A 15 WEEK BAN
WHEN YOU ARE STARING AT 15 AND
YOU HAVE THESE TRIGGER LAWS, GET
SOMETHING DONE THAT THEN YOU
HAVE TO PUT MODERATE REPUBLICANS
ON THE BACK FOOT IN THE SENATE
AND THEY HAVE TO COME FORWARD
AND EXPLAIN WHY THEY WANT TO
TAKE THIS MIDDLE GROUND
APPROACH.
15 WEEKS, SAY MISS EUROPE, WITH
THE MISSISSIPPI LAWS AND TO MAKE
THEM A DECISION.
THEY WILL PASS SOMETHING IN
CONGRESS AND IT WILL STAY ON THE
SENATE AND WE'LL BE BACK BACK TO
SQUARE ONE.
I THINK WHAT WE SAW FROM
JOE BIDEN, AND I DON'T THINK
THAT HIS COMMENT WAS ANYWHERE
NEAR HAVING THE IMPACT, BECAUSE
TALKING ABOUT MAGA REPUBLICANS
IS SEPARATE.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE THAT
ARE BIG TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND
PEOPLE OF BEEN CALLING LIBERALS
PEOPLE WITH -- CROOKED HILLARY.
>> 90% SUPPORT INSIDE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> AT 60 MILLION PEOPLE,
70 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM.
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY HELP THE
COUNTRY.
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD PARTICIPATE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
VOTE FOR A PERSON WHO IS ON THE
BALLOT BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT THE
POLICIES OF THE PARTY WHEN THEY
DON'T REALLY LIKE THE PERSON.
>> THEY DIDN'T USE HIS NAME,
THEY JUST SAID MAGA.
>> THAT WAS HIS MODEL.
HIS SLOGAN WAS "MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN," THAT IS WHERE MAGA
CAME FROM.
>> IT OFFENDS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> IS A P.R. PERSON, THERE IS A
LOT A LOT.
>> SOMEBODY DID, HE SAID IT
ABOUT 14 TIMES.
LET ME GO TO PETE.
ONE OF THE THINGS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE DID NOT SEEM
CONCERNED ABOUT AT ALL TODAY AND
JEN PSAKI DID NOT SEEM TO HAVE
ANY RESPONSE, WAS THE DOCKS
ENOUGH -- THE INFORMATION ON THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, THE FIVE
JOINED IN THIS OPINION SO THAT
PEOPLE COULDN'T PROTEST IN FRONT
OF THEIR HOMES.
THAT IS TYPICAL OF WHAT THE LEFT
DOES.
THE RIGHT DOESN'T DO THAT.
THOSE OF THE PEOPLE, THAT IS WHY
THEY CALL IT.
WHY CAN'T THE WHITE HOUSE
CONDEMN THAT?
>> THEY HAVEN'T EVEN COME OUT
AND SAID -- LET ALONE THE DOCKS
ENOUGH SUPREME COURT NUMBERS SO
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO
INTIMIDATE THEM AT THEIR HOMES,
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO FAR DOWN THE
TRAIN THAT THEY SAY THAT SPEECH
ITSELF IS VIOLENT.
AND THEREFORE IN RESPONSE TO
THAT SPEECH, VIOLENCE IS
JUSTIFIED.
POLITICS IS RELIGION TO THEM AND
AS A RESULT, THE ENDS ALWAYS
JUSTIFY THE MEANS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, THEY
ARE RAMPING UP THE FEAR.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
ALTERNATIVES.
EVEN THOUGH EVERYONE KNOWS THIS
IS GOING BACK TO THE STATES, THE
CONGRESSMAN SAID.
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN AN ABORTION
BAN.
>> THEY LIVE IN THOSE STATES.
>> YOU ARE YELLING.
NO ONE ELSE WAS YELLING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE VOTE FOR.
THEY VOTE FOR --
>> THAT IS WHAT DEMOCRACY TALKS
ABOUT.
THEY ARE RAMPING UP THE FEAR ON
THE MAGA CROWD.
DEMONIZE THE OPPONENT AND MAKE
THE OPPONENT THE BAD GUY.
AND HOPE YOU CAN WIN.
>> GREG, IT COMES TO YOU.
BUT THERE ARE A COUPLE VERSIONS
RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE LEFT IS
NOW TRYING TO CONVINCE EVERYONE,
THIS IS THE END OF GAY MARRIAGE,
RACIAL MARRIAGE CONTRACEPTIVE.
WHEN THE OPINION IS THREE
SEPARATE PLACES, THIS DECISION
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THOSE
OTHER CASES.
SPEAKER THEY ARE COUNTED ON THE
FACT THAT NO ONE IS GOING TO
READ IT.
IT NORMALLY DOES FOR PEOPLE --
YOU READ IT, I DIDN'T READ IT.
I KNOW YOU ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH.
FOR MOST PEOPLE, THEY ARE ON
THEIR PHONES DOING OTHER STUFF.
SO WHEN THEY ARE THE STUFF FROM
JOE BIDEN, HE COMBINED THROUGH
DIFFERENT ISSUES WHEN HE IS
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT -- YOU DON'T
GET MAD ABOUT IT, YOU GET SAD.
BECAUSE IT'S AN EMPTY VESSEL
PEER THAT IS WHY REPEATED THE
SLOGAN FOR THE SOFTWARE WAS PUT
IN.
THEY PUT THE MAGA SOFTWARE IN
AND IT SPUTTERED AND CAME TO
LIFE AND HE GOT STUCK.
MAGA, MAGA, MAGA.
THIS IS THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF A
COMMENT OR SMEAR.
WHEN EVERYTHING ABOUT TRUMP
BEING MEAN OR WHATEVER, HE WENT
AFTER THE MEDIA.
HE WENT AFTER POLITICIANS,
CELEBRITIES, AND EVEN ATHLETES.
HE NEVER REALLY -- I DON'T THINK
HE EVER SINGLED OUT A DEMOCRATIC
VOTER OR DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
THE SALESMAN WANTS TO GET
EVERYBODY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS -- THE
DEMOCRAT LEADERS PUNCHED DOWN.
THEY DO IT INTO HIS, THEY SMEAR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE THEY
CHASING AN INDIVIDUAL DOWN IN
THE MEDIA WHETHER IT IS FOR
POSTING A MEME OR WEARING A MAGA
HAT.
BUT THIS IS PART OF A LARGER
TREND, WHICH IS BECAUSE THE
MODERN WOKE FRAMES EVERYTHING AS
MORAL OR IMMORAL WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT RELIGION, IT'S
ACTUALLY FLIP FROM THE
REPUBLICANS OF THE 80s.
THE MAJORITY IS NOW ON THE LEFT.
UNTIL THERE'S -- HE WAS ABLE TO
EXPLODE WITHOUT ANY BREAKS.
NOBODY COULD COME TO THE BREAKS,
BECAUSE THE BRAKES OR
FORGIVENESS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IS AN
INCREDIBLE FLIP.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LESS FORGIVING
AND MORE JUDGMENTAL AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE THE OPEN TIMES.
YOU ARE SHOWING ALL OF THESE
REPUBLICANS -- YOU ARE GETTING
PEOPLE THAT WOULD NORMALLY HAVE
EXCELLENT ROLES.
THIS IS AN OVERARCHING THEME IF
YOU LOOK AT THE MASKS AGAINST
THE UNMASKED, THE DENIGRATION OF
PARENTS.
LETTING THEM EAT CAKE NARRATIVE
ABOUT FOOD SHORTAGES AND GAS
PRICES BEAR THERE'S A DISDAIN
FOR THE UNWASHED MASSES.
THAT WAS THE STEREOTYPE.
BUT SECRETLY, SO HAS B